kendall jenner shuts down the haters who
threw shade over a fashion choice she
made two months ago back in november the
26 year old model found herself under
fire for rocking this black cutout gown
to a friend's wedding in miami the dress
which features large diamond-shaped
cutouts down the chest and stomach
showed quite a bit of skin and got
people on twitter talking they love it
yeah not so much when the bride lauren
perez posted throwback pics to instagram
on december 31st in celebration of the
new year some fans were quick to cast
judgment on kendall's look with one
instagram user calling the ensemble
quote inappropriate for a wedding adding
quote i'm embarrassed for you hashtag
cringe and another calling the look
quote blatantly disrespectful
but the bride was quick to step in and
say that kendall her close friend quote
looked stunning in fact lauren says she
loved it
and that's when the keeping up with the
kardashians star swooped in explaining
that she didn't just show up to her
friend's nuptials in a scene-stealing
gown quote avi i asked for your approval
in advance too we love a beach wedding
and speaking of weddings beyond
speculated last week that kendall and
her boyfriend nba star devin booker had
maybe already tied the knot themselves
after the lovebirds soaked up some cozy
cabin vibes on new year's eve the couple
who has been pretty private about their
romance even shared some rare pda pics
ringing in 2022
devin shared this shot of his leading
lady alongside the caption spent new
year's by a fire and kendall she shared
a series of pics from the romantic
getaway 2 writing my weekend
but it was this shot that really had
people talking look closely and you'll
see the athlete holding a glass of wine
with what appears to be a gold band on
his left ring finger fans were quick to
point out the accessory in the comments
but others noted that it's actually a
mirror image so that ring is actually on
his right ring finger and while devin
and kendall may not be ringing wedding
bells yet they are sharing their love
with fans more than ever before in
november the pro athlete posted this
snap to his insta story in honor of his
girlfriend's birthday writing most
beautiful woman in a second pick devin
hugs kendall from behind with a lock
emoji and while the two might be sharing
more of their relationship on social
media than before you might not want to
get too used to it it's not always easy
but i don't know i just kind of i like
to keep my private life pretty private
so
um i try my best but at the same time i
don't i don't like to let
being seen out in public with someone
like affect my everyday life
back in june during the keeping up with
the kardashians reunion special kendall
opened up about keeping her love life to
herself
kylie and i specifically have had the
opportunity to watch my older sisters go
through marriages and
and relationships and breakups and all
these things and do them pretty publicly
and like again no offense to you guys at
all but i think just it was personal
preference
from like a really young age that i
didn't really want to like
yeah i think it makes my life a lot
easier and our relationship a lot
better to be completely honest i just
feel like it's a private matter it's not
really for anybody else to to judge or
know
[Music]
you